طائرات مروحيه عسكريه اسرائيليه تقصف في
جنين حدث نادر في المشهد الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي لم يحدث منذ الانتفاضه الثانيه
من عام وحتى 2005 مؤشر اذا على ان الوضع
في الضفه الغربيه يتجه للاشتعال وبراي
الكثيرين الى الانفجار مع تلميح وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي عمليه عسكريه واسعه
فالظروف مهيئه وضاغطه
[موسيقى]
وفي المشهد المتغيرات كثيره وان بدات
الامور في الفتره الماضيه تسير في نمط
متسق متكرر احتجاجات في تل ابيب اشتباكات
في الضفه صعيد في غزه ثم تهدئه ظروف
استثنائيه تحكم مناخ القضيه الساخن جاءت
بها حكومه يمنيه هي الاشد التطرفا وتشددا
وتمسكا صهيونيه دينيه تضغط احزابها على
ائتلاف تهدده
بالتفككات اسرائيليه مرهونه بارضاء جمهور
المستوطنين مع مقتل اعداد منهم وعمليات
لعناصر حماس تتجاوز حدود القطاع تصل الضفه
الغربيه في وقت تبرز قدره نوعيه لدى
الفلسطينيين على مجاهد اليات اسرائيليه
تضع الحجاره والمولوتوب خيارا تاما وثالث
امام اسلحه بات تتصل الى الايادي وكل هذا
له نقطه اشتعال شراره انطلقت واخمادها غير
مؤكد
[موسيقى]
فلسطين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات